et frédéric des premières historiques il
pourrait y en avoir d'autres là ce
scrutin demain oui céline ailleurs les
femmes occupent une place de choix dans
ces petites première historique d'abord
on va aller faire un tour en arizona
patrie évidemment du défunt john mc cain
est là quoi qu'il arrive c'est une femme
qui va remporter l'un des sièges au
sénat parce que ces deux candidats qui
s'opposeront à la républicaine une
pilote de chasse martha max ehrlich et
les républicaine que le stand cinéma une
démocrate très populaire qui revendique
sa bisexualité pour l'instant elle
serait favorite la républicaine mais on
va voir ce qui va se passer mais c'est
une femme ça c'est sûr autre femme cette
fois ci au tennessee qui est en bonne
position pour le remporter
tennessee évidemment à ces républicains
marsha blackburn serait également la
première dans cet état a accédé au sénat
fils personne n'a pas vraiment de chance
de l'emporter si on va maintenant à la
chambre des représentants on est au
kansas et le midwest et ultra
conservateur et bien figurez vous que la
personne qui risque de remporter
c'est une démocrate spécialiste des arts
martiaux mixtes lesbiennes et
amérindiennes en club et avec elle le
rend plus vraiment le profil idéal du
kansas mais pourtant elle risque de
gagner face au républicain kevin yodel
si on se déplace maintenant du côté du
michigan est bien là aussi une première
assez importante
une candidate musulmane qui n'a pas
d'opposants républicain dans un conte
est vraiment très très bleu très
démocrate
c'est une femme d'origine palestinienne
est pas très loin de là on va dire du
côté du minnesota cette fois ci on a une
autre candidate musulmane qui a de
fortes chances de l'emporter parce que
c'est très libérale là bas cette femme
est aux états unis depuis douze ans et
une réfugiée somalienne
elle risque fort de l'emporter devant la
conservatrice jennyfer zielinski
beaucoup entendu parler pendant cette
mort s'il ya beaucoup de femmes donc
mais aussi les courses exclusivement
masculine
oui parlons justement de course du
gouverneur encore une fois une première
en floride
ce serait probablement angie l'homme qui
va l'emporter ce serait le premier
gouverneur afro américain de l'histoire
de l'état c'est le maire de talais à 6
et puis nous avons un rôle de santis qui
lui fait pâle figure actuellement dans
les sondages c'est le candidat de
monsieur jobs
autre cas aussi intéressant cette fois
ci au colorado c'est probablement jared
polis le démocrate qui va l'emporter un
candidat ouvertement gai là aussi
une première au colorado ce qui peut
importe les résultats en france mais
vous l'avez montré assez bien il ya
beaucoup de diversité dans ce scrutin
quelques chiffres pour terminer céline
d'abord le nombre de femmes il y en a 2
172 qui se présente pour les différentes
chambres
c'est plus du quart de la population des
candidats 216 personnes de couleur au
soir multiraciale et nous avons 26
personnes qui se réclament de la
communauté lgbt
enfin derniers chiffres 58 % d'hommes
blancs c'est le pourcentage qui se
présente aux élections
c'est le plus faible taux depuis les
quatre dernières élections céline
intéressant merci free